this is my face after I've been told I
have 10 minutes to live I was a fake
missile Alert in Hawaii yes I was there
my assistant Linda called me she was
crying she said we have 10 minutes left
she said the missiles are coming I
remember this they sent out an emergency
text to everybody it's completely real
to us try to get off the island of my
daughter I couldn't get off the island I
sat on the Lanai and looked out at the
ocean at that point I just uh I started
going okay well what could I do with
this last moment of time and I just
decided to go through a list of
gratitudes and honestly God I could not
stop thinking of wonderful things that
have happened to me and it was a
surprise that I actually slipped into
this lace of gratitude it was lovely and
I got to a point of Grace but about two
minutes to spare when I found out it
wasn't actually happening it's a weird
thing to walk around the world knowing
how you'll be in the last 10 minutes of
your life uh and what did you do when
you find out that it was a fake missile
test then I got pissed off